the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I minus X I transpose
ok I just pick whatever notation I want
for my variable and let's eight-speed
it's t ok so that's the least squares
estimator and it turns out that as I
said last time it's going to be
convenient to think of those things as
matrices all right so here I already
have vectors right I've already gone
from one dimension just real valued
random variables to random vectors when
I think of each X i but if i start
stacking them together i'm gonna have
vectors and matrices that show up so the
first vector I'm getting is Y which is
just a vector where I have Y 1 2 y n
then I have so that's a bold-faced
vector then I have X which is a matrix
where I have well the first coordinate
is also always 1 ok so I have 1 and then
X 1 X P minus 1 and that's sorry X 1 X P
minus 1 and that's for observation 1 and
then I have the same thing all the way
down for observation n
ok everybody understands what this is
I'm just basically stacking up all the X
ice right so this I throw is X I
transpose Y I'm just stacking them up
and so if I want to write all these
things to be e to be true for each of
them all I need to do is to write a
vector epsilon which is epsilon 1 2
epsilon N and what I'm going to have is
that why the boldface vector now is
equal to the matrix X
time's the vector beta plus the vector
Epsilon okay and it's really just
exactly saying what's there because for
two so this is a vector right this is a
vector and what what is the dimension of
this vector and right so this is n
observations and for all this for two
vectors to be equal I need to have all
the coordinates to be equal and that's
exactly the same thing as saying that
this holds for I could want you AK but
now when I have this I can actually
rewrite the sum for T equals sorry for I
equals 1 to N of Y I minus X I transpose
beta squared this turns out to be equal
to the Euclidean norm of the vector Y
minus the matrix X sine beta squared ok
and I'm gonna put a 2 here so we you
know we're talking about the Euclidean
norm right this just means this is you
clean right that's the one we've seen
before when we talked about Chi square
that's the square norm is the sum of the
square of the coefficients and then I
take a square root but here I have an
extra square so it's really just the sum
of the square of the coefficients which
is this and here the coefficients okay
so there that I write by this this thing
like that then minimizing so my goal
here now is going to solve minimum over
T in our P of Y minus X times t2 squared
and just like we did for one dimension
we can actually write optimality
conditions for this I mean this is a
function right so this is a function
from R P to R and if I want to minimize
it all I have to do is to take its
gradient and set it
to zero okay so minimum set gradient to
zero so that's where it becomes a little
complicated right now I'm gonna have to
take the gradient of this norm it might
be a little annoying to do but actually
what's nice about those things I mean I
remember that it was a bit annoying to
learn I mean it's just like basically
rules of of calculus that you don't use
that much but essentially you can
actually expand this norm and you will
see that the rules are basically the
same as in one dimension you just have
to be careful about the fact that
matrices do not commute
okay so let's expand this thing y minus
x2 squared well this is equal to the
norm of Y squared plus the norm of X T
squared plus two times y transpose X T
right
that's just expanding the square in more
dimensions and this I'm actually going
to write as Y squared plus so here the
norm squared of this guy I always have
that the norm of x squared is equal to X
transpose X right so I'm gonna write
this as X transpose X so it's T
transpose X transpose X T plus two times
y transpose X T okay so now if I'm going
to take the gradient with respect to T I
have basically three terms and each of
them has some sort of a different nature
this term is linear in T and it's going
to differentiate the same way that I do
French a times X right I'm just gonna
keep the a this guy is quadratic and T
appears twice and this guy I'm gonna
pick up a two and it's going to
differentiate just like when I
differentiate a times x squared it's two
times ax
okay and this guy is a constant with
respect to t so it's gonna differentiate
to zero okay so what I compute the
gradient now of course every all these
rules that I give you can check by
looking at the partial derivative with
respect to each coordinate but arguably
it's much faster to know the rules of
differentiability it's like if I give
you the function exponential X and I
said what its derivative and you started
writing well I'm gonna write the
exponential X plus h minus exponential X
AG X divided by H and let H go to zero
that's a bit painful I'm sorry
the transpose of to a B is D transpose a
transpose if you're not sure about this
just make a and B have different size
and then you will see that there's some
not incompatibility I mean there's
basically only one way to not screw that
one up so that's easy to remember all
right so if I take the gradient then
it's going to be equal to what that's
going to be zero plus we said here this
is going to differentiate like so think
a times x squared so I'm gonna have to
ax so here basically this guy is gonna
go to X transpose X T now I could have
made this one go away but that's the
same thing as saying that my gradient is
I can think of my gradient as being
either a horizontal vector or vertical
vector so if I remove this guy I'm
thinking of my grain as being horizontal
if I remove that guy I'm thinking of my
vector my gradient as being vertical and
that's what I want to think of typically
vertical vectors right column vectors
and then this guy well it's like this
guy's just think eight times X right so
the derivative is just a so I'm gonna
keep only that part here sorry I forgot
a minus somewhere yeah here
- - y transpose X and what I want is
this thing to be equal to zero right
so T the optimal T is called B the hat
and satisfies well I can cancel the twos
and put the minus on the other side and
what I get is that X transpose X T is
equal to Y transpose X and that's yeah
that's not working for me yeah that's
because when I took the derivative I
still need to make sure so it's the same
question of whether I want things to be
columns or rows right so this is not a
column right if I remove that guy Y
transpose T is a row so I'm just gonna
take the transpose of this guy to make
things work and this is just going to be
X transpose Y
and this guy is X transpose y so that I
have columns okay so this is just a
linear equation in T and I have to solve
it so it's of the form some matrix time
T is equal to another vector and so
that's a basic linear system and the way
to solve it at least formally is to just
take the inverse of the matrix on the
left okay so if x transpose x is
invertible then sorry that's beta hat is
the t I want I get that beta hat is
equal to X transpose X inverse X
transpose Y and that's the least squares
estimator
so here I use this condition right I
want it to be invertible so I can
actually write its inverse here I wrote
rank of X is equal to P what is the
difference
well there's basically no difference
right basically here I have to assume
what is the size of the matrix x
transpose x yes so what is the size P by
P right so this matrix is invertible if
it's of rank P if you know what rank
means if you don't that just rank P
means that it's invertible all right so
it's full rank and it's invertible and
the rank of XX transpose of x transpose
s is actually just the rank of x because
this is the same matrix that you apply
twice and that's all it's saying so if
you're not comfortable with the notion
of rank that you see here just think of
this condition just being the condition
that x transpose x is invertible and
that's all it says what it means for it
to be invertible this was true right we
made no assumption up to this point it
if x is not invertible it means that
there might be multiple solutions to
this equation right in particular for
matrix to not be invertible it means
that there's some vector V so if x
transpose x is not invertible then this
is equivalent to there exists a vector V
which is not 0 and such that x transpose
x v is equal to 0 right that's what it
means to not be invertible so in
particular if beta hat is a solution so
this equation is sometimes called score
equations because the gradient is called
the score and so you're just checking if
the gradient is equal to 0 so if been a
hat satisfy star then so does
Vita hat plus lambda V for all lambda in
the real line right and the reason is
because well if I start looking at what
is x transpose x times beta hat plus
lambda V well by linearity this is just
X transpose X beta hat plus lambda X
transpose X time V but this guy is what
it's zero right just because that's what
we assumed we assume that X transpose X
V was equal to zero so we're left only
with this part which by star is just X
transpose Y so that means that X
transpose X beta hat plus lambda V is
actually equal to X transpose Y which
means that there's another solution
which is not not just beta hat but any
move of beta hat along this direction V
and then by any size so that's going to
be an issue right because you're finding
you're looking for one estimator and
there's not just one in this case
there's many and so this is not gonna be
well-defined and you're gonna have some
issues so if you want to talk about D
least squares estimator you have to make
this assumption what does it imply in
terms of can I think of P being 2n for
example in this case what happens if P
is equal to 2n
so the rank of your matrix is only P
over 2 right so that means that this is
actually not gonna happen right d I mean
it's not only P over 2 it's at most P
over 2 right it's that most the smallest
of the two dimensions of your matrix so
if your matrix is n times 2n it's at
most n which means that it's not gonna
be full rank so it's not gonna be
invertible so every time the dimension P
is larger than the sample size your
matrix is not invertible and you cannot
talk about the Lea squares estimator so
that's something to keep in mind and
it's actually a very simple thing it's
essentially saying well if P is larger
than n it means that you have more
parameters to estimate then you have
equations to estimate it right so you
have this linear system there's one
equation per observation right each row
which was each observation was giving me
one equation but then the number of
unknowns in this linear system is P and
so I cannot solve linear systems that
have more unknowns than they have
equations and so that's basically what's
happening now in practice if you think
about what data sets look like this days
for example people are trying to express
some phenotypes and few tone type is
something you can measure on people
maybe out are the color of your eyes or
your height or whether you have diabetes
or not things like this right so things
that you know are sort of macroscopic
and then they want to use the genotype
to do that right they want to measure
your they want to sequence your genome
and try to use this to predict whether
you're gonna be responsive to a drug or
whether your ours are gonna be blue or
some clientís now the data sets that you
can have people maybe for a given study
about I don't know some sort of disease
maybe you will you know sequence the
genome of maybe a hundred people right n
is equal to 100 P is basically the
number of genes they're sequencing this
is of the order of a hundred thousand so
you can imagine that this is a case
where n is much much smaller than P and
you cannot talk about the least squares
estimator there's plenty of them there's
not just one line like that when that
times V that you can move away there's
basically an entire space in which you
can move and so it's not well-defined so
at the end of this class I will give you
assurance
reduction on how you do this like this
actually represent more and more becomes
a more and more preponderant part of the
data sets you have to deal with because
people just collect data right
when I do the sequencing you know the
machine allows me to sequence a hundred
thousand genes I'm not gonna stop at a
hundred because you know doctors are
never gonna have cohorts of more than a
hundred patients so you just collect
everything you can collect and this is
true for everything you know cars have
sensors all over the place much more
than they actually gather data there's
data there's you know we're creating
we're recording everything we can and so
we need some new techniques for that and
that's what high dimensional statistics
is trying to answer so this is way
beyond the scope of this class but
towards Deanna we'll give you some hints
about what can be done in this framework
because well you know which is this is
the new reality we have to deal with ok
so here we are in a case where pees less
than n that typically much smaller than
n so the kind of orders of magnitude you
want to have is maybe P's of order 10
and n these of order 100 something like
this so you can scale that but maybe 10
times larger
all right so maybe you cannot solve this
guy B for B hat but actually you can
talk about x times V hat even if P is
lower than n and the reason is that x
times B hat is actually something that's
very well-defined so what is x times B
hat right remember I started - I started
with the model so if I look at this
definition essentially what I had as a
original thing was that the vector Y was
equal to x times beta plus the vector
Epsilon that was my model right so beta
is actually giving me something beta is
actually some some parameter some
coefficients that are interesting but a
good estimator for so here it means that
the observations that I have are of the
form x times beta plus some noise so if
I want to just the noise remove the
noise a good candidate to the noise is x
times beta hat right x times beta hat
something that should actually be useful
to me which should be close to two x
times beta so in the one-dimensional
case what it means is that if I have
let's say this is the true line and
these are my X's so I have these are the
true points on the real line and then I
have my little epsilon that just give me
my observations that you know move
around this this line right so this is
this is one of the epsilon say epsilon I
then I can actually either talk to say
that I recovered the line I can actually
talk about recovering the right
intercept or recovering the right slope
for this line right those are the two
parameters that I need to recover but I
can also say that I've actually found a
set of points that's closer to being on
the line then the then that that are
closer to this set of points right here
then the original crosses that I
observed right so if we go back to the
picture here for example what I could do
is say well for this point here right
there was an X here rather than looking
at this dot which was my observation I
can say well now that I've estimated the
red line I can actually just say well
this point should really be here and
actually I can move all these dots so
that they're actually on the red line
and this should be a better value
something that has less noise than the
original Y value that I should see it
should be close to the true value that I
should be seeing without the extra noise
so that's definitely something that
could be of interest right for example
in imaging you're not trying to
understand so when you do imaging Y is
basically an image right so think of a
pixel image and you just stack it into
one long vector and what you see is
something that should look like some
linear combination of some feature
vectors right some maybe so there's
people have a bunch of created a bunch
of features it's their Co for example
Gabor frames or wavelets transform so
just like well-known libraries of
of variables X such that when you take
linear combinations of those guys this
should look like a bunch of images and
and what you want for your image you
don't care what the coefficients of the
image are in this basis that you came up
with what you care about is the noise in
the image and so you really want to get
X beta alright so if you want to
estimate X beta well you can use X beta
hat and the way what is X beta hat well
since X beta which sings beta hat is X
transpose X inverse X transpose Y this
is X transpose right that's my estimator
for X beta now this thing actually I can
define even if I'm not low rank so why
is this thing interesting well you know
there's a formula for this estimator but
actually I can visualize what this thing
is so let's assume for the sake of
illustration that n is equal to 3 okay
so that means that Y lives in a
three-dimensional space and so let's say
it's here okay and so I have my let's
say Y is here and I also have a plane
that's given by the vectors X 1
transpose X 2 transpose which is by the
way a 1 sorry that's not what I want to
do I'm gonna say that n is equal to 3
and that P is equal to 2 so I basically
have two vectors 1 1 and another one
let's let's assume that it's for example
I don't know ABC
so those are my two vectors right this
is X 1 and this is X 2 okay and those
are my three observations for this guy
so what I want when I'm in Imai is I'm
looking at the point which can be form
as a linear combination of the columns
of X and I'm trying to find the guy
that's the closest to Y so what does it
look like well the two points 1 1 1 is
going to be say here that's the point 1
1 1 and let's say that ABC is this point
ok so now I have a line that goes
through those two guys ok that's not
really okay let's say it's going through
those two guys and this is the line
which can be formed by looking only at
linear combinations so this is the line
four of x transpose x T for T in our -
alright that's this entire line that you
can get why is it yeah sorry it's not
just a line I also have to have T all
the zeros thing right so that actually
creates an entire plane which is going
to be really hard for me to represent I
don't know it's maybe I shouldn't do it
in in these dimensions okay so I'm gonna
do it like that so this plane here is
the set of X T 14 r2 okay so that's a
two dimensional plane tip definitely
tick goes through zero and those are all
these things right so think of a sheet
of paper in three dimension those are
the things I can get so now what I'm
gonna have is y is not necessarily in
this plane Y is actually something in
this plane X beta
plus some epsilon okay why is X beta
plus Epsilon
so I start from this plane and then I
have this epsilon that pushes me maybe
outside of this point and what least
squares is doing is saying well I know
that epsilon should be fairly small so
the only thing I'm going to be doing
that actually makes sense is to tick Y
and look at find the point that's on
this plane that's the closest to it and
that corresponds to doing an orthogonal
projection of Y onto this thing and
that's actually exactly X beta hat okay
so in one dimension just because this is
actually a little hard in one dimension
so so that's if P is equal to one okay
so let's say this is my point and then I
have Y which is in two dimensions so
this is all on the plane but it does
this is my the point that's right here
is actually X beta hat that's how you
find X beta hat you take your point Y
and you project it on the linear span of
the columns of X and that's X beta hat
this does not tell you exactly what beta
should be and if you know the little bit
of linear algebra it's pretty clear
because you if you want to find beta hat
that means you should be able to find
the coordinates of a point in the system
of of columns of X and if those guys are
redundant there's not going to be a
unique coordinate for this guy's right
so that's why it's actually not not easy
to find but X beta hat is uniquely
defined it's the projection ya know
epsilon is the vector that goes from
right so there's so there's a true X
beta that's the true one this is it's
not clear I mean X beta hat is unlikely
to be exactly equal to X beta right and
then the epsilon is the one that starts
from this line it's the vector that
pushes you away so really this is this
vector that's Epsilon
so it's not a length right the length of
exelon is the distance but epsilon is
just the actual vector that takes you
from one to the other okay so this is
all in two dimension it's probably much
clearer than what's here and so here I
claim that this X beta hat so from this
picture I sort of implicitly claim that
forming this this operator that takes Y
and maps it into this vector X times X
transpose Y blah blah blah this should
actually be equal to the projection of Y
onto the linear span of the columns of X
all right so that's what I just drew for
you and what it means is that this
matrix must be the projection matrix
okay so of course anybody who is who
knows linear algebra here okay so so if
what is the what are the conditions that
a projection matrix should be satisfying
squares to itself right if I project
twice I'm not moving if I keep on
iterating projection once I'm in the
space I'm projecting onto I'm not moving
what else
didn't have to be symmetric moving yeah
so this is an orthogonal projection it
has to be symmetric and that's pretty
much it right so those from those things
you can actually get quite a bit of
things but what's interesting is that if
you actually look at the eigenvalues of
this matrix they should be either 0 or 1
essentially and there are one if the
eigenvector associated is within the
space and zero otherwise and so that's
basically what you can check this is not
an exercise in the air algebra so I'm
not going to go too much into those
details but this is essentially what you
want to keep in mind what's associated
to orthogonal projections is Pythagoras
theorem and that something is going to
be useful for us but it's essentially
telling me is that if I look at this
norm squared it's equal to this norm
squared sorry this norm squared plus
this norm squared is equal to this norm
squared and that's something the norm of
Y squared right so pitagoras tells me
that the norm of Y squared is equal to
the norm of X beta hat squared plus the
norm of Y minus X beta hat square agreed
right is just because I have I have a
street angle here okay so that's this
okay so now to define this I made no
assumption epsilon because it could be
as Wald I was just crossing my finger
that epsilon was actually small enough
that it would make sense to project onto
the linear span because I implicitly
assumed that epsilon did not take me all
the way there so that them actually it
sort of makes sense to project back and
so for that I need to somehow make
assumptions that epsilon is well behaved
and that it's not completely wild that
it's sort of moving in uniformly in
directions around in all directions of
the space there's no privileged
direction where it's always going
otherwise
gonna make a systematic error and I need
that those Epsilon's are gonna average
somehow okay so here are the assumptions
we're gonna be making so that we can
actually do some statistical inference
the first one is that the design matrix
is deterministic okay so I started by
saying the X I have X I Y I and maybe
they're independent here they are but
the exercise I want to think as
deterministic if they're not
deterministic it can sort of condition
on them but otherwise it's very
difficult to think about this thing if I
think of those entries as being random
because then I have the inverse of a
random matrix and things become very
very complicated so we're gonna think of
those guys as being deterministic we're
gonna think of the model as being
homoscedasticity Mosca DAST ik well I
mean if you try to find the etymology of
this word homo means the same sky - tech
means scaling so what I want to say is
that the epsilon have the same scaling
and since my third assumption is that
epsilon is Gaussian then essentially
what I'm gonna want is that they all
share the same Sigma squared they're
independent so this is definitely the
identity covariance matrix and I want
them to be centered as well that means
that I there's no direction that I'm
always privileged in what I'm moving
away from my plane there ok so these are
important conditions if it depends on
how much inference you want to do right
if you want to write t-test you need all
these assumptions but if you only want
to write for example the fact that your
least squares estimator is consistent
you really just need the fact that
epsilon has variance Sigma squared the
fact that it's Gaussian won't matter
just like Gaussian it doesn't matter for
a law of large number yeah
X X is the matrix no that's the
assumption yeah so this is for the
purpose of the analysis right I can
actually assume that I just look at my
data and I think of this right so what
is the difference between thinking of
data as deterministic or thinking of it
as random when I talked about random
data
the only assumptions that I made were
about the distribution I said well if my
X is a random variable I wanted to have
this variance and I wanted to have maybe
this distribution things like this here
I'm actually if I'm actually making the
an assumption on the values that I see
I'm saying that the value that you give
me is the matrix is actually invertible
x transpose x will be invertible so i've
never done that before assuming that
some random variable like you know
assuming that some Gaussian random
variable was positive for example we
don't do that because there's always
some probability that things don't
happen if you make things at random and
so here I'm just gonna say okay forget
about here actually it's basically a
little stronger I start my assumption by
saying the data that's given to me will
actually satisfy those assumptions and
that means that I don't actually need to
make some random some modeling
assumption on this thing because I'm
actually putting directly the Assumption
I want to say okay okay so here either I
know Sigma square or I don't know Sigma
square so is that clear so essentially
I'm assuming that I have this model
where this guy now is deterministic and
this is some multivariate Gaussian with
mean zero and covariance matrix identity
of all right right that's that's the
model I'm assuming so and I'm observing
this and I'm given this matrix X where
does this make sense right you could say
well if I think of my rows as being
people and I'm collecting genes it's
kind of a little intense to assume that
I actually
know ahead of time what I'm gonna be
seeing and that those things are
deterministic that's true but it still
does not prevent the analysis to go
through for one and second a better
example might be this imaging example
that I described where those X's are
actually libraries right those are
libraries of patterns that people have
created maybe from deep learning nets or
something like this but they've created
patterns and they say that all images
should be representable as a linear
combination of those patterns and those
patterns are somewhere in books so
they're certainly deterministic
everything that's actually written down
in the book is that's the termina stick
as it gets alright ok any questions
about those assumptions those are the
things we're gonna be working with
there's only three of them one is about
X actually there's really two of them
right I mean this guy already appears
here right so there's two one on the
noise one on the X's that's it those
things allow us to do quite a bit they
allow us to they allow me well that's
actually ok they allow me to write the
distribution of beta hat which is great
right because when I know the
distribution of my estimator
I know its fluctuations if it's centered
around the true parameter I know that
it's gonna be fluctuating around the
true parameter and if you tell me what
kind of distribution the fluctuations
are I actually know how to build
confidence intervals I know how to build
tests I know how to build everything
it's just like when I told you that
asymptotically the empirical variance
was Gaussian with mean theta and
standard deviation that depended on and
etc that's basically the only thing I
needed and this is what I'm actually
getting here so let me start with this
statement
so remember beta hat satisfy this so I'm
gonna rewrite it here
so beta hat was equal to X transpose X
inverse X transpose Y right that was the
definition that we found and now I also
know that Y was equal to X beta plus
Epsilon
so let me just replace Y by X beta plus
epsilon here yeah now yes X transpose
thank you okay so I'm gonna replace Y by
X beta plus Epsilon okay so that's okay
and here comes the magic right I have an
inverse of a matrix and then I have the
true matrix I have the original matrix
so this is actually the identity times
beta and now this guy well this is a
Gaussian right because this is a
Gaussian random vector and I just
multiply it by a deterministic matrix so
right so we're gonna use the rule that
if I have say epsilon which is n 0 Sigma
then B times epsilon is n 0 can somebody
tell me what the covariance matrix of B
epsilon is it's just a matrix
and for any matrix I mean any matrix
that I can pre multiply that can post
multiplied with Epsilon right yeah B
transpose and Sigma is going that's the
matrix right almost anybody wants to
take it yes at the last one I think
we've removed all other possibilities
it's B Sigma B transpose okay so if you
ever answer to the question do you know
Gaussian random vectors but you did not
know that there's a gap in your
knowledge that you need to fill because
that's probably the most important
property of Gaussian vectors when you
take you multiply them by matrices you
have a simple rule on how to update the
covariance matrix okay so here Sigma is
the identity all right and here this is
the matrix B that I had here so what
this is is basically n sum multivariate
and of course then I'm going to have
zero and so what I need to do is B times
the identity times B transpose which is
just BB transpose and what it's gonna
tell me it's it's X transpose X I'm
sorry that's inverse inverse X transpose
and then the transpose of this guy which
is X X transpose X inverse transpose but
this matrix is symmetric so I'm actually
not gonna make the transpose of this guy
and again magic shows up inverse times
the matrix so those two guys cancel and
so this is actually equal to beta plus
sum and zero X transpose X inverse yeah
so I just apply this rule right so if I
multiply a Gauss a matrix by a Gaussian
then let's say there this make this
Gaussian hat mean zero which is the case
of epsilon here then the covariance
matrix that I get is B times the
original covariance matrix times B
transpose so all I did is write this
matrix times the identity times this
matrix transpose and the identity of
course doesn't play any role so I can
remove it as just this matrix time the
matrix transpose and what happens so
right so what is the transpose of this
matrix so I sort of used the fact that
if I look at X transpose X inverse X
transpose and now I look at the whole
transpose of this thing that's actually
equal to and I use the rule that a B
transpose is B transpose a transpose let
me finish and it's X X transpose X
inverse yes
oh thank you there's a sigma square
somewhere so this was Sigma squared
times day this was Sigma squared times
the identity so I could just pick up a
sigma square everywhere right so here in
our case so for epsilon this is this is
uh Sigma right Sigma squared times the
identity that's my covariance matrix
you've seen purflex oh it should not be
any estimator is a random variable and I
have not told you that this was the
maximum likelihood estimator just yet
right an estimator is the random
variable there's a word some people use
estimate just to differentiate the
estimator while you're doing the
analysis with random variables and the
values when you plug in the numbers in
there but then of course people use
estimate because it's shorter so then
it's confusing and all right so any
questions about this computation did I
forget any other Greek letter along the
way all right that thing we're good
so one thing that it says and actually
thank you for pointing this out they
said there's actually a little hidden
statement there right okay by the way
this answers this question right beta
hat is of the form beta plus something
that's centered so it's indeed of the
form Gaussian with mean beta and
covariance matrix Sigma square X
transpose X inverse right so that's very
nice as long as X transpose X is not
huge I'm gonna have something that that
is close to what I want I'm sorry X
transpose X inverse is not huge
alright so there's a hidden claim in
there which is that the like least
squares estimator is equal to the
maximum likelihood estimator why does
the maximum I like here with estimator
just enter the picture now we've been
talking about regression for the past 18
flights and we've been talking about
estimators and I just dumped on you the
least squares estimator but I never
really came back to this thing that we
know maybe the method of moments or
maybe the maximum likelihood estimator
it turns out that those two things are
the same but if I want to talk about a
maximum likelihood estimator I need to
have a likelihood in particular I need
to have a density and so if I want a
density I have to make those assumptions
such as the Epsilon's have this Gaussian
distribution so why is this the maximum
likelihood estimator well remember Y is
x transpose beta plus Epsilon so I
actually have a bunch of data so what is
what is my model here well it's the
family of gaussians on n observations
with mean X beta variance Sigma square
identity and beta lives in our p here's
my family of distributions right that's
the possible distributions for Y and so
in particular I can write the density of
Y well what is it it's something that
looks like P of X well P of Y let's say
is equal to 1 over so now it's gonna be
a little more complicated but it's Sigma
squared times 2 pi to the P over 2
exponential
- norm of Y minus X beta squared divided
by 2 Sigma squared ok so that's just the
multivariate Gaussian density I just
wrote it that's the density of a
multivariate Gaussian with mean X beta
and covariance matrix Sigma squared
times the identity that's what it is
ok so you don't have to learn this by
heart but if you are familiar with the
case where P is equal to 1 you can check
that you recover what you're familiar
with and and and this sort of makes
sense as an extension so now I can
actually write my log likelihood right
how many observations do I have of this
vector Y
you'll have n observations of why I have
just one right this I'm sorry that's
sorry I shouldn't have said P this is n
right everything is in dimension n so I
have I can think of either having n
independent observations of each
coordinate or I can think of having just
one observation of the vector Y so when
I write my log-likelihood it's just the
log of the density at Y and that's the
vector Y which I can write as minus n
over 2 log Sigma square 2 pi minus 1 hat
1 over 2 Sigma squared norm of Y minus X
beta and that's again my boldface Y ok
and what is my maximum likelihood
estimator well this guy does not depend
on beta and this is just a constant
factor in front of this guy so it's the
same thing
I was just minimizing because I have a
minus sign over all beta in RP Y minus X
beta squared and that's my least squares
estimator okay
is there anything that's unclear on this
board any question right so all I use
what I wrote by log-likelihood which is
just the log of this expression where Y
is my observation and that's indeed the
observation that I have here and that
was just some constant minus some
constant times this quantity that
depends on beta so maximizing this whole
thing is the same thing as minimizing
only this thing the minimizer's are the
same and so that tells me that I
actually just have to minimize the
square norm to get my maximum likelihood
estimator but this used heavily the fact
that I could actually write exactly what
my density was and and and that when I
took the log of this thing I had exactly
the square norm that showed up if I had
a different density if for example I
assumed that my coordinates of one of
Epsilon's worse aiit exponential double
exponential random variables right so
it's just half of an exponential and the
process half of an exponential on the
negatives so if I said that then this
would not have the square norm that
shows up this is really idiosyncratic
two gaussians if I had something else I
would have maybe a different norm here
or something different measures the
difference between y and and B X beta
and that's how you come up with other
maximum likelihood estimators that leads
to other estimators that are not the
least squares maybe the least absolute
deviation for example or you know this
Fourth Movement for example that you
suggested last time so I can come up
with a bunch of different things and
they might be tied maybe I can come up
from them from the same perspective that
I came from the least squares estimator
I said let's just do something smart and
check then that it's indeed the maximum
likelihood estimator or I could just
start with the modeling on and check
then what happens if what was the
implicit assumption that I put on my
noise or I could start with the
assumption of the noise compute the
maximum likelihood estimator and see
what it turns into
alright so that was the first thing I'm
just I've just proved to you the first
line
and from there you can get what you want
right so all the other lines are gonna
follow so what is beta hat so for
example let's look at the let's look at
the second line the quadratic risk beta
hat minus beta from this formula has the
distribution which is N and zero and
then I have X transpose X inverse right
sorry the dimension of what oh yeah you
right knee right here right that was all
P dimensional there
yeah because right so if I if B here the
matrix am I actually applying has
dimension P times n so even if epsilon
was an N dimensional Gaussian vector
then B times epsilon is a P dimensional
Gaussian vector now all right so that's
how I switch from P to n from n to P
thank you all right so you're right this
is beta hat minus beta is this guy and
so in particular if I look at the
expectation of the norm of beta hats
minus beta squared what is it it's the
expectation of the norm of some Gaussian
vector I'm sorry of the norm yeah of the
norm of some Gaussian vector and so it
turns out so maybe we can don't have
well okay that's just also property of a
Gaussian vector right so if epsilon is n
0 Sigma then the norm the expectation of
the norm of epsilon square is just the
trace of Sigma actually we can probably
check this by saying that this is this
from Jayco 1 to p of the expectation of
beta j minus beta hat j minus beta j
squared since beta j squared is the
expectation beta g is the expectation of
beta hat this is actually equal to the
sum from J equal 1 to P of the variance
of beta hat J right just because this is
the expectation of beta hat and how do I
read the variances in a covariance
matrix
there's just the diagonal elements right
so that's really just Sigma JJ and so
that's really equal to so that's the sum
of the diagonal elements of this matrix
let's call it Sigma so that's equal to
the trace of X transpose X inverse ok
the sum of the trace is the sum of the
diagonal elements of the matrix and I
still had something else I'm sorry this
is not this with Sigma Square and I
forget it all the time so the Sigma
square comes out it's there and so the
Sigma square comes out ok because the
trace is a linear operator if I multiply
all the entries of my matrix by some the
same number then all the diagonal
elements are multiplied by the same
numbers and when I sum them the sum is
multiplied by the same number
ok so that's for the quadratic risk of
beta hat and now I need to tell you
about X beta hat right X beta hat was
something that was actually telling me
that that was the point that I reported
on the red red line that I estimated
right that was my X beta hat that was my
my sorry my Y minus the noise
now this thing here so remember we had
this line and I had my observation and
here I'm really trying to measure this
distance squared this distance is
actually quite important for me because
it actually shows up in the pizza in
particular
theorem right and so you can actually
try to estimate this thing so what is
the prediction error so we said we have
Y minus X beta hat so that's the norm of
this thing and we're trying to compute
but let's write this for what it is from
one second right so we said that beta
hat was X transpose X inverse X
transpose Y and we know that Y is X
transpose beta plus Epsilon
so let's write this X beta plus epsilon
was X okay and actually maybe I should
not write it let me keep the Y for what
it is now okay so that means that I have
essentially the identity of our end
times y minus this matrix times y so I
can factor y out and that the identity
of our n minus X X transpose X inverse X
transpose the whole thing times y we
said that this we call this matrix P
because this was the projection matrix
onto the linear span of the axis right
so that means that if I have I take a
point X and I apply P times X I'm
projecting onto the linear span of the
columns of X what happens if I do I
times P Phi I minus P times X it's X
minus px right
so if I look at the point on which so
this is the point on which I project
this is X
i project orthogonal ii to get P times X
and so what it means is that this
operator I minus px is actually giving
me this guy this vector here X minus P
times X let's say this is zero this
means that this vector I can pour it
here as this vector here and that's
actually the orthogonal projection of X
onto the earth there good old compliant
of the span of the columns of x-ray so
if I do X if I project X or if I look at
X minus its projection and basically
projecting onto two orthogonal spaces
which what I'm trying to say here is
that this year is another projection
matrix P Prime
it's just the projection matrix onto the
orthogonal projection onto orthogonal of
column span of X our struggle means the
set of vectors that's our signal to
everyone in this cell in this linear
space so now when I'm doing this this is
exactly what I mean in a way this is
sort of illustrating this Pythagoras
theorem and so what I want to compute
the norm of this guy the norm squared of
this guy I'm really computing if this is
my Y now this is px of Y I'm really
controlling the norm squared of this
thing
okay so if I want to compute the norm
squared
so I'm almost there so what am i
projecting here onto the orthogonal
projector right so here why now I know
that Y is equal to X beta plus Epsilon
right so when I look at this matrix P
prime times y it's actually P prime
times X beta plus P prime times Epsilon
what's happening to P prime times X beta
let's look at this picture right so we
know that P prime takes any point here
and projects it orthogonal e on this guy
but X beta is actually a point that
lives here right it's something that's
on the linear span so where do all the
points that are on this line get
projected to the origin to 0 right they
all get projected to 0 and that's
because I'm basically projecting
something that's on the column span of X
onto its orthogonal so that's always 0
that I'm getting here so when I apply P
prime to Y I'm really just applying P
prime to Epsilon ok so I know that now
this actually is equal to the norm of
some multivariate Gaussian what is the
size of this Gaussian what is the size
of this matrix well I actually had it
there it's I n right so it's n
dimensional so it's some n dimensional
with mean 0 and what is the covariance
matrix of P prime times Epsilon
yeah P prime P prime transpose right
which we just said P transpose is P
prime transpose is P so that's P squared
and we see that when we project twice
it's as if we projected only once so
here this is n 0 P prime P prime
transpose that's the formula for the
covariance matrix but this guy is
actually equal to P prime times P prime
which is equal to P Prime so now what
I'm looking for is the norm squared of
the trace so that means that this whole
thing here is actually equal to this to
the trace oh did I forget again an
epsilon a sigma square yeah I forgot it
only here which is good news all right
so I should assume that Sigma square is
equal to 1
so Sigma squares here and then what I'm
left with is Sigma square times the
trace of P Prime at some point I
mentioned that the eigenvalues of a
projection matrix were actually 0 or 1
the trace is the sum of the eigenvalues
so it means that the trace is going to
be an integer number is the number of
nonzero eigenvalues and the nonzero
eigenvalues are just the dimension of
the space onto which i'm projecting now
i'm projecting from something of
dimension n onto the orthogonal of a
space of dimension p what is the
dimension of the orthogonal of a space
of dimension p when thought of of space
in dimension n n minus p right that's
the so-called rank the erm i guess as
name and so that's how i get this n
minus p here this is really just equal
to n minus p yeah
yes you're right so that's actually the
expectation of this thing that's equal
to that absolutely but I actually have
much better right I know even that the
norm that I'm looking at I know it's
gonna be this thing what is it going to
be the distribution of this guy norm
squared of a Gaussian Chi square so
there's gonna be some Chi square that
shows up and the number of degrees of
freedom is actually going to be also n
minus P and maybe it's actually
somewhere yeah right here n minus P
times Sigma hat squared over Sigma
squared this is my Sigma hat squared if
I multiply n minus PM left only with
this thing and so that means that I get
Sigma square times because I always
forget my Sigma square I get Sigma
square times this thing it turns out
that the square norm of this guy is
actually exactly a chi square with my n
minus P degrees of freedom okay so in
particular right so we know that the
expectation of this thing is equal to
Sigma square times n minus P so if I
divide both sides by n minus P I'm going
to have that something whose expectation
is Sigma square and this something I can
actually compute right it depends on Y
and X that I know and beta hat that I've
just estimated I know what n is and P
arse or the dimensions of my matrix X so
I'm actually given an estimator whose
expectation is Sigma square and so now I
actually have an unbiased estimator of
Sigma square that's this guy right here
and it's actually super useful all right
that's something it's basically so those
are called the this is the normalized
sum of square residuals this is recalled
of residuals right those are whatever is
residual when I project my points onto
the line that I've estimated and so in a
way those guys if you go back to this
picture this was Y I and this was X X I
transpose beta hat right so if beta hat
is close to beta the difference between
Y I and X I transpose beta should be
close to my epsilon I
all right it's some sort of epsilon I
hat agreed and so that means that if I
think of those as being epsilon I hat
they should have they should be close to
epsilon I and so their norm should be
giving me something that looks like
Sigma squared and so it's that's why it
actually makes sense is just magical
that everything works out together
because I'm not projecting on the right
line I'm actually projecting on the
wrong line but in the end things
actually work out pretty well okay
there's one thing so here the theorem is
that this thing not only has the right
expectation but also has a chi-squared
distribution that's what we just
discussed so here I'm just telling you
this but it's not too hard to believe
because it's actually the norm of some
vector you couldn't make this obvious
but again I didn't want to bring in too
much linear algebra so to prove this you
actually have to diagonalize the matrix
P so you have to invoke the eigen value
decomposition and the fact that the norm
is invariant by rotation so for those
who are familiar with what I can do is
just look at the decomposition of P
Prime into you DS u transpose where this
is an orthogonal matrix and this is the
diagonal matrix of eigen values and when
they look at the norm squared of this
thing I mean I have basically the norm
squared of P prime times some Epsilon
it's the norm of U D u transpose epsilon
squared the norm of a rotation of a
vector is the same as the norm of the
vector so this guy goes away this is not
actually I mean you don't have to care
about this if you don't understand what
I'm saying so don't freak out this
really for those who follow what is the
distribution of U transpose epsilon I
take a Gaussian vector that has
covariance matrix Sigma squared I see an
entity that I basically rotate it what
is its distribution yeah it's the same
as completely invariant right because
the Gaussian think of all directions as
being the same so it doesn't really
matter if I take your Gaussian or a
rotated Gaussian
so this is also a Gaussian so I'm gonna
call it epsilon Prime and I'm left with
just the norm of epsilon primes
so this is the sum of the DJ's squared
times epsilon J squared right and we
just said that the eigenvalues of p are
either 0 or 1 because it's a projector
and so here I'm gonna get only zeros and
ones so I'm really just summing a
certain number of epsilon I squared so
square root of standard gaussians sorry
with a sigma square somewhere and and
basically how many do i am i summing
well the n minus p the the number of
nonzero eigenvalues of p prime so that's
how it shows up okay this when you see
this
what's theorem what theorem am i using
here Cochrane's theorem this is this
magic book I'm actually gonna dump
everything that I'm not gonna prove to
you and say well this is actually
conferences now her crimes theorem is
really just telling me something about
orthogonality of things and therefore
independence of things and Cochrane's
theorem was something that I used what I
wanted to use what that's something I
use just one slide before student t-test
right I use Cochran's theorem to see
that the numerator and the denominator
of the student statistic were
independent of each other and this is
exactly what I'm gonna do here I have
I'm gonna actually write a test to test
maybe though beta J's are equal to 0 I'm
gonna form a numerator which is beta hat
minus beta this is normal we know that
beta hat is as a Gaussian distribution
I'm gonna standardize by something that
makes sense to me and I'm not gonna go
into details because we're out of time
but there's the Sigma hat that shows up
and then there's a gamma J which takes
into account the fact that my X's right
if I look at the distribution of beta
which is your honor things
yeah beta is gone oh yeah that's where
he where that's where it the covariance
matrix depends on this matrix X
transpose X so this will show up in the
variance right in particular diagonal
elements are gonna play a role here and
so that's what my gammas are the gammas
is GI agonal element of this matrix so
we'll resume that on on Tuesday but but
so don't worry too much this is not
gonna if this is going to faster is I'm
not supposed to cover it but just so you
get a hint of why Cochran's theorem
actually was useful all right so I don't
know if we actually ended up recording I
have your homework and as usual I will
give it to you outside